what's up everybody man Luigi here and
Dark Souls 3 is out I know there are
going to be a lot of new players and
even some veterans I would like to hear
the fundamentals that we came so in this
video I'll be going over the basics and
tutorial area Dark Souls 3 giving tips
and advice on things that I find
important let's start off with class
choice honestly this isn't too big of a
decision once you get rolling in the
game you can customize your build to fit
how you want to play however I think the
most important thing in the early game
is health for vitality so choosing class
with high vitality like the knight or
warrior will give the most benefit I'd
suggest the black fire bombs as a burial
gift as these will be a lot of help
during your first boss fight getting
into the game obviously the gameplay is
going to parallel the previous souls
games one of the biggest changes being
focused points linked with webinars
you'll pick up your ashen Estus clasp
right away this will refill your blue FP
or focus point mark weapon arts the
special attacks that happen when you to
hand the weapon and sorceries magic
miracles all during this blue bar so if
you think you're going to be using any
or all of these frequently this new blue
flask will be a great friend tutorial
messages on the ground will guide you
through the basic controls and move sets
of your character locking on lunge
attacks parries and the like are all
almost identical to previous titles and
are explained by the orange notes once
you've dispatched all of the undead head
towards the light for a beautiful view
and your first bonfire don't worry I
haven't forgotten that intriguing
crevice that was beckoning to you before
the light
head back there to find a giant crystal
is gravely dangerous enemy stay close to
its back and watch out for its
area-of-effect crystals make sure to
roll if you get caught out of position
has the invincibility frames and rolls
are nearly paramount to the gameplay of
the series Dark Souls 3 has only two
types of roll either fat rolling or
normal should almost never fat roll
which occurs when a player is wearing
too much gear as it severely limits your
mobility and dodging potential by this
point in the game your normal rolling
and you will want to keep it that way
don't stack on too much heavy gear as
you progress you should be able to
whittle the beast down runs back and
eventually fell it netting you a
titanite scale an item of great benefit
in terms of weapon upgrading back at the
bonfire the area is strife with undead
there are two points of interest here
near the cliff side the path branches
down revealing two undead brandishing a
spear and a crossbow respectively try
luring the spearmen out of the crust was
range to illuminate him then head in and
finish off the ranged attacker here you
will find some normal fire bombs which
will be very useful in a few moments on
the other side of the area there will be
a small drop of the tutorial guide
telling you how to jump get a running
start and leap off the edge aiming for
the center of the grave this will gain
you Titan a chart an item you will
become very familiar with once you begin
upgrading your weapons now you're ready
to face the first boss head over to the
kneeling armor and remove the coiled
sword
thus begins the fight with you Dex
gun-deer this fight has two phases like
actually a lot of bosses in Dark Souls 3
phase one is where you start with
gun-deer and is Alvar keep your distance
from em studies attack pattern use your
role to dodge yet at the same time
position yourself strike be patient and
strike a few uses his moveset watch out
for his elbow bash that will
occasionally follow a help strike this
can drain your stamina for blocking and
set you up to take a lot of damage from
his next attack once you get gun-deer to
around half health phase two begins the
you Dex will transform spread out a huge
black snake and claw this is where those
fiery bombs will come in handy using the
black and/or normal fire bombs depending
on what you chose for your burial gift
keep your distance from the boss and
launch your bombs the black creature is
weak to fire so a couple of these bombs
will go a long way these should take out
the majority if not all of its health
and you can quickly roll in and attack
it once or twice to finish up the job
Congrats you just be your first Dark
Souls 3 boss you may notice a bit of
glowing and increase in health this is
normal
every time you beat a boss or use the
item Ember your ember will be restored
and you'll be put in Lord of cinders
mode this gives a 40 percent increase to
your health and allows you to summon
other players into your world to partake
and some jolly cooperation this is
basically like this game's humanity or
human effigy the next area love a few
enemies and items scattered about it
that'll mainly be left up to your
exploration inside the building named
Firelink shrine will be a bonfire
yearning for that coiled sword you
yanked out of gun dears ribs and a
couple of MPs who serve vital purposes
the fire keeper can level you up the
shrine handmaiden will sell a range of
useful items and buy yours
Aundre the blacksmith will reinforce
Estus flasks and improve in fuse and
repair weapons blood lifts will
eventually be able to transpose boss
souls into weapons and the crestfallen
will be thoroughly depressing but we are
talking true legends with the metal
delete the file we don't fit to lick
their boots don't you think
and maybe he'll talk about a couple
major plot points and motivations of
your character if you walk up the right
staircase inside the shrine there will
be a great lock tower and drop soul the
small tree near here will provide access
to the roof if you can manage the semi
challenging jump just keep trying and be
persistent you'll get it
pick up the homework bones on the roof
which allow you to teleport back to the
bonfire you last rested at or the shrine
bonfire and head into the ceiling of the
shrine so annoying birds will begin
squawking you can trade with them by
driving an item around their nest and
seeing if they like it if they do
they'll trade it out for a different
item or gesture the item on the walkway
next to the bird area is an estes chard
which if taken to the blacksmith will up
the number of swigs that can be taken
from your Estus flask back at the
ceiling on the opposite side where you
came in there will be an illusionary
wall you can break which will lead to a
chest holding the coveted silver serpent
ring your first ring this raises the
number of souls dropped by enemies if
you have it equipped the last thing you
want to check out before really starting
the game proper will be on the opposite
side of fire link relative to the lock
tower here you'll find the old master a
very powerful katana wielder this is a
very very strong foe so patience is the
key here as you're just backing up and
letting him do the sweeping weapon art
then striking after he does that be
careful because he's really good at
parry
either you kill him or you die enough
times that he disappears and you'll be
able to pick up his gear especially the
very powerful ug Tonga because Tama he
was using which is a personal favorite
weapon of mine returning from previous
souls games the weapon requires a bit of
skill points into dexterity to use but I
feel it's definitely well worth it these
scales well dexterity and it's a very
powerful early game weapon now you're
ready to level up whatever you want
health is powerful and rewarding early
investment however so is Dex now that
you have that katana choose your path
and take a seat at the bonfire warp to
the high wall of lothric you're now
ready and prepared for the beast that is
Dark Souls 3 enjoy